US President Donald Trump's got a green
light to impose 7.5 billion dollars
worth of tariffs on goods exported from
the EU the ruling by the World Trade
Organization is the largest in its
history and is part of a 15-year battle
of illegal subsidies made to European
plane maker Airbus the new tariffs could
hit as soon as the 18th of October and
will include a 10% levy on European
aircraft and 25% on popular food items
like scotch whiskey and French cheese
Brussels has warned that it's ready to
retaliate if the u.s. decides to impose
WTO authorize countermeasures it will be
pushing the EU into a situation where we
will have no other option than to do the
same meanwhile an Italian journalist
seized an opportunity to voice her
position on the route by handing the US
Secretary of State a large wedge of
Parmesan cheese
the encounter happened during a photo-op
between Mike Pompeo and Italy's Prime
Minister in Rome on Wednesday
[Music]
the US trade office says it expects to
enter talks with the EU in a bid to
resolve the dispute we spoke to a
political science professor about the
impact this all has on Western relations
so if you've gone to start that dispute
within the Alliance and enter alliance
rivalry between the United States and
the EU then this threatens the unity of
the Western bloc the fact that the u.s.
is taking this WTO ruling to impose such
severe tariffs on EU Goods reflects
either some severe problems economic
problems in the United States or a
possible positioning for some sort of
action in the world perhaps military
action under the current situation with
President Trump he is definitely
asserting that dominance and he is
demanding that Europe subordinate itself
to us demands the European leaders are
not okay with this number one but number
two they are caught because they don't
have any way out
you